you ended up uh working with mozzie
which uh obviously free mozzie yeah I
think I put you guys on text together
the day we did that interview yeah um
you tell you told me you're still
keeping in contact with him you wrote
him in jail like talk about your guys's
relationship fast forward a year and
some change man so it's so crazy because
we did our interview here you asked me
who I would work with if I could work
with anybody I said Mozzy this was
before meeting him following on social
media anything yeah somehow we got we
got in in touch I think like I put you
guys on a group chat yeah and then on
the spot yeah and then a month later it
happened I came to Cali
I remember at the interview you were
like it's the most people I've ever seen
in my studio I had like my whole
neighborhood with me we went into his
Studio he did the song on the spot and
then he was like what y'all doing after
let's shoot the video which like a
rapper never says to you yeah nobody
ever wants to shoot the video Kiss
actually said to me he was like damn
when's the last time you did a song for
a rapper that you're bigger than and
then asked him to shoot the video